مرحبا بكم في قناه الجزيره تعهد الرئيس
الروسي لازم يفوتن بتحقيق جميع اهداف
بلاده في اوكرانيا وقال ان كل الصراعات
تنتهي بالدبلوماسيه متهم
لاطاله امل الحرب عقب زياره تاريخيه
للرئيس الاوكراني الى الولايات المتحده
تخللها الاعلان عن مساعدات عسكريه
لاوكرانيا منها منظمات
اكد بوتن ان المنظومه قديمه واقل كفاءه من
المنظومه الروسيه اس 300 متعهدا بتدميرها
حاله نقلها الى اوكرانيا
هذا ناطق باسم قياده الجيش الاوكراني
السركيه الشريفاتي ان الجيش استعاد
السيطره بشكل كامل على مدينه باخموت واضاف
في تصريح من الجزيره ان المدينه تتعرض
لقصف المكثف بالصواريخ بعد اخراج القوات
الروسيه منها
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لقواتها تواصل
التقدم في محور وانها قضت على نحوي 50
عسكريه الاوكرانيا من جهه اخرى
الروسيه في منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
باوكرانيا
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي ان الرئيس الروسيه
الى شركه فاجنر ساب الصعوبات في تجنيد
الروس للقتال في اوكرانيا
ان شركه تعاني من خسائر بشريه فادي
قتلت شرطه والاحتلال الاسرائيلي شابا
فلسطينيات في مدينه كفر قاسم داخل الخط
الاخضر في ذريعه تنفيذه عمليه اطلاق نار
ودهسن مزدوجه اسفلت عن اصابه فردين من
قواتها بجروح طفيفه وقالت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه ناعثرت على قطعه سلاح داخل
المركبه التي استخدمت الهجوم وزجاجات
حارقه وذخيره في مبنى قرب موقع الهجوم
خلال عمليات التمشيط والبحث عن مشتبهم بهم
اخرين وقد نفت عائلته الشهيد نعيم بدير اي
يكون ابنها قد قام بتنفيذه هجوم على عناصر
الشرطه الاسرائيليه وقالت انه قتل بدمن
بارد
افادت مراسله الجزيره في واشنطن ان
التقرير المفصل والنهائي للجنه التحقيق
التي شكلها مجلس النواب الامريكي للنظر في
احداث اقتحام الكونجرس اشار الى تورط
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
للصفه الاجراميه في مؤامره متعدده الاذراع
لقلب النتائج القانونيه لانتخابات 2020
وذكره التقرير ان ترامب فشل في منعه
انصاره من اقتحامه مقر الكونجرس
انتهى الموجز شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]